- That's what it
was, it was stupid.
That's really what he said.
(laughter)
- Hey, hey, hey, yes, I saw
you guys waving me over.
My name's Orgy, short for Organ.
And, what about
me, what about me?
I was born--
- Oh, we just wanted to order.
- Gotch, no, no,
no, no, no, totally.
That's why you call
the old 'tress over.
Gotta get the dull
stuff out of the way
before we can just
start chilling.
You know, just, smoking inside.
You know what, our nachos
here are pretty incredible.
- We'll get a pitcher
and some nachos.
- Good choice alert,
ring, ring, ring, ring!
Ring the alarm, you know?
I'll go put that in,
I'll be right back,
I'll be right back.
I will be back.
(laughs)
- So, let me say, I
just, I think like--
♪ I wanted to check
on my table pals ♪
♪ I put your order in ♪
♪ So we can hang out ♪
- Beer's here, cheers!
♪ Cups, cups, cups,
I drink it all up ♪
- You guys know that one?
- Could we get some cups?
- What're you guys
doing tonight, huh?
You goin' to a base-b game
because you're so
obsessed with pitchers.
♪ It would be so fun ♪
♪ To hang out with you ♪
♪ You know, I just
started as your waiter ♪
♪ But we bonded and we joked ♪
♪ I can tell there's
something special ♪
♪ I would save you
if you choked ♪
♪ Because that's what
friends are for ♪
- Off.
When do you think those
nachos will be ready?
Yeah, we don't serve that.
We don't serve nachos, I
lied to impress you guys.
If you need anything,
just scream at me!
(upbeat music)